good morning
a central responsibility for any
government is to do what's necessary for
economic stability
this is vital for businesses making
long-term investment decisions
and the families concerned about their
jobs their mortgages and the cost of
living
no government can control markets
but every government can give certainty
about the sustainability of public
finances
and that is one of the many factors that
influence how markets behave
and for that reason although the Prime
Minister and I are both committed to
cutting corporation tax
on Friday she listened to concerns about
the mini budget
and confirmed we will not proceed with
the cutter corporation tax announced
the government has today decided to make
further changes to the mini budget
and to reduce unhelpful speculation
about what they are
we've decided to announce these ahead of
the medium-term fiscal plan which
happens in two weeks
I'll give a detailed statement to
Parliament this afternoon
and answer questions from MPS
but because these decisions are Market
sensitive I've agreed with the speaker
the need to give an early brief summary
of the changes which are all designed to
provide confidence and stability
we will reverse almost all the tax
measures announced in the growth plan
three weeks ago that have not started
parliamentary legislation
so whilst we will continue with the
abolition of the Health and Social care
Levy and stamp Duty changes we will no
longer be proceeding with the cuts to
Dividend tax rates the reversal of off
payroll working reforms introduced in
2017 and 2021 the new vat-free shopping
scheme for non-uk visitors or the freeze
on alcohol Duty rates
secondly the government's current plan
is to cut the basic rate of income tax
to 19
from April 2023.
it is a deeply held conservative value
a value that I share
that people should keep more of the
money they earn
but at a time when markets are rightly
demanding commitments to sustainable
public finances it is not right to
borrow to fund this tax cut
so I've decided that the basic rate of
income tax will remain at 20 percent
and it will do so indefinitely until
economic circumstances allow for it to
be cut
taken together with a decision not to
cut corporation tax
and restoring the top rate of income tax
the measures I've announced today will
raise every year around 32 billion
pounds
finally the biggest single expense in
the growth plan was the energy price
guarantee
this is a landmark policy supporting
millions of people through a difficult
winter
and today I want to confirm that the
support we are providing between now and
April next year will not change
but beyond that the Prime Minister and I
have agreed it would not be responsible
to continue exposing public finances to
unlimited volatility in international
gas prices
so I'm announcing today a treasury-led
review into how we support energy bills
Beyond April next year
the objective is to design a new
approach that will cost the taxpayer
significantly less than planned
whilst ensuring enough support for those
in need
any support for businesses will be
targeted to those most affected
and the new approach will better
incentivize Energy Efficiency
the most important objective for our
country right now is stability
governments cannot eliminate volatility
in markets
but they can play their part
and we will do so because instability
affects the prices of things in shops
the cost of mortgages and the values of
Pensions
there will be more difficult decisions
I'm afraid on both tax and spending as
we deliver our commitment to get debt
falling as a share of the economy over
the medium term
all departments will need to redouble
their efforts to find savings and some
areas of spending will need to be cut
but as I promised at the weekend our
priority in making the difficult
decisions that lie ahead will always be
the most vulnerable
and I remain extremely confident about
the UK's long-term economic prospects as
we deliver our mission to go for growth
but growth requires confidence and
stability
and the United Kingdom will always pay
its way
this government will therefore take
whatever tough decisions are necessary
to do so
thank you